i mean i i do
wonder just like we've been talking
about if there's any ways to push that
to its limits to
explore further i don't like leaning
this
this is why i'm bothered there's not
more science and psychedelics is
i haven't done almost so i've
eaten mushrooms a few times uh allegedly
but that's it you know and i the reason
i don't do more the reason i haven't
done dmt
is because it's illegal and it's like
not
well studied and it you know i
i'm in those things i'm not usually at
the cutting edge but i'm very curious
and it feels like
there could be tools to be discovered
there
not for fun not for recreation but for
like encouraging whether you're a linear
thinking to go non-linear or it's
non-linear to go linear
like to to shake things up you mentioned
dan gable
the idea of dan gable on psychedelics is
fascinating to me because
he's such a control freak i mean
that i would show up for that that would
not show up for but
like so much of these psychedelic
experiences it feels like is for letting
go
that's right you don't want to resist
but that's supposedly where the growth
is
in in giving oneself over to the process
and that's for people who are like
master
controllers he's one of the greatest
coaches of all time it's fascinating to
see what that battle looks like
of resistance and then of letting go uh
yeah i mean
i i can't wait to uh to uh to see where
these studies takes us
but it's clearly happening you know i've
asked there i have a couple colleagues
at stanford who are doing animal studies
i've asked around you know it's there's
a lot of discussion
in the neuroscience community about what
the perception of a laboratory is
if they work on psychedelics i mean
i i have to tip my hat to the folks at
hopkins they are pioneers
and as um terry signowski he's a
computational neuroscientist down at
salk says i don't think he was the first
person to say he says uh
you know how to spot the pioneers
they're the ones with the arrows in
their backs
yeah and you know it's it's an unkind
world
to a scientist that's trying to do
really cutting edge stuff my colleague
david spiegel who studies medical
hypnosis it's he's got
dozens of studies now showing that
hypnosis can be beneficial for pain
management anxiety management cancer
outcomes
it's finally you know at the point where
there's so much data
but people hear hypnosis and they think
of stage hypnosis which is like the
furthest thing from what he's doing
and i think mind body
type stuff hypnosis respiration and
breathing i think the hard science
walk into the problem is always going to
be best to get the community on board
and then it's up to people like matt and
um
to really you know take it to the next
level and as i say not
keezy out of the game because kizi
basically was taking
too much of his own stuff and he started
dressing crazy at banana hats and like
you see him he had
the magic bus so you know the day so
like the day i start driving to work in
the magic bus
that's the day i lose my job i'm not
into buses or
or wearing fruit but you're going to get
a phone call from me and i hope you do
the same for me it's like
like dude what are you doing
you